And for some reason we call this atypical,
even though, as I mentioned, women do make up half the population.
And so what is some of the evidence to help explain some of these differences?
If we look at the anatomy,
the blood vessels that surround the heart are smaller in women compared to men,
and the way that those blood vessels develop disease is different
in women compared to men.
And the test that we use to determine if someone is at risk for a heart attack,
well, they were initially designed and tested and perfected in men,
and so aren't as good at determining that in women.
And then if we think about the medications --
common medications that we use, like aspirin.
We give aspirin to healthy men to help prevent them from having a heart attack,
but do you know that if you give aspirin to a healthy woman,
it's actually harmful?
What this is doing is merely telling us
that we are scratching the surface.
Emergency medicine is a fast-paced business.
In how many life-saving areas of medicine,
like cancer and stroke,
are there important differences between men and women that we could be utilizing?
Or even, why is it that some people get those runny noses
more than others,
or why the pain medication that we give to those stubbed toes
work in some and not in others?
The Institute of Medicine has said every cell has a sex.
What does this mean?
Sex is DNA.
Gender is how someone presents themselves in society.
And these two may not always match up,
as we can see with our transgendered population.
But it's important to realize that from the moment of conception,
every cell in our bodies --
skin, hair, heart and lungs --
contains our own unique DNA,
and that DNA contains the chromosomes that determine
whether we become male or female, man or woman.
It used to be thought
that those sex-determining chromosomes pictured here --
XY if you're male, XX if you're female --
merely determined whether you would be born with ovaries or testes,
and it was the sex hormones that those organs produced
that were responsible for the differences we see in the opposite sex.
But we now know that that theory was wrong --
or it's at least a little incomplete.
And thankfully, scientists like Dr. Page from the Whitehead Institute,
who works on the Y chromosome,
and Doctor Yang from UCLA,
they have found evidence that tells us that those sex-determining chromosomes
that are in every cell in our bodies
continue to remain active for our entire lives
and could be what's responsible for the differences we see
in the dosing of drugs,
or why there are differences between men and women
in the susceptibility and severity of diseases.
This new knowledge is the game-changer,
and it's up to those scientists that continue to find that evidence,
but it's up to the clinicians to start translating this data
at the bedside, today.
Right now.
And to help do this, I'm a co-founder of a national organization
called Sex and Gender Women's Health Collaborative,
and we collect all of this data so that it's available for teaching
and for patient care.
And we're working to bring together the medical educators to the table.
That's a big job.
It's changing the way medical training has been done since its inception.
But I believe in them.
I know they're going to see the value of incorporating the gender lens
into the current curriculum.
It's about training the future health care providers correctly.
And regionally,
I'm a co-creator of a division within the Department of Emergency Medicine
here at Brown University,
called Sex and Gender in Emergency Medicine,
and we conduct the research to determine the differences between men and women
in emergent conditions,
like heart disease and stroke and sepsis and substance abuse,
but we also believe that education is paramount.
We've created a 360-degree model of education.
We have programs for the doctors, for the nurses, for the students
and for the patients.
Because this cannot just be left up to the health care leaders.
We all have a role in making a difference.
But I must warn you: this is not easy.
In fact, it's hard.
It's essentially changing the way we think about medicine
and health and research.
It's changing our relationship to the health care system.
But there's no going back.
We now know just enough
to know that we weren't doing it right.
Martin Luther King, Jr. has said,
"Change does not roll in on the wheels of inevitability,
but comes through continuous struggle."
And the first step towards change is awareness.
This is not just about improving medical care for women.
This is about personalized, individualized health care for everyone.
This awareness has the power to transform medical care for men and women.
And from now on, I want you to ask your doctors
whether the treatments you are receiving are specific to your sex and gender.
They may not know the answer --
yet.
But the conversation has begun, and together we can all learn.
Remember, for me and my colleagues in this field,
your sex and gender matter.
Thank you.
(Applause)